if this video gets 5000 elite tweets my
mom is going to buy me an Xbox these
guys can we smash 5,000 likes on this
video and CEO of YouTube Susan Wojcicki
has agreed to take me to prom please
guys if this video gets elon musk's will
send me to space and leave me there
that's right
haters no more YouTube videos begging
for likes it's something that we all do
hashtag relatable leave a like if you
agree on that one but wendice begging
for likes just become too much too
annoying sometimes I like to sneak a
little hey guys did you enjoy this video
but some people just take it too far
some people have no integrity and they
just start yelling they start screaming
ah it makes me angry
what are you begging for likes it's gone
it's gone too far
you've gone two steps too far it makes
me so mad I could snap my back in the
Hat right now the new trend of begging
for likes has become can I get better
grades please for retweets you may have
seen this tweet it got hundred and
thirty seven thousand retweets hundred
thousand retweets and mr. fryer will bub
my 89.2% to a ninety percent from last
semester probably won't happen but we'll
try
we will try to get me a better grade
apparently a lot of people obviously
bought into this I mean it got 137
thousand retweets no I'm not salty that
this got more retweets than my
engagement that's not it at all okay
this is the dumbest I've ever seen
I don't know how the American school
system works I don't know how grades
work they're basically what we had at
least in university was three is past
and five is maximum so you either get
nothing three four or five and then you
get a beverage from that if it works
somewhat similar that she needs a 4.0
I'm sorry but you suck why are so many
people retweeting this and why did this
teacher I remember there was just no way
in my school that you could even sweet
talk anything about changing the grade
if you thought the teacher could made a
mistake you could bring that up and be
like hey sorry you corrected this but I
think the injection should be like this
it happened and the teacher would change
it but doing it for retweet I'm sorry
but what the hell that's the dumbest
thing I've ever seen I worked so damn
hard okay so no one else should get
anything for free people shouldn't get
things for free now apparently this is
not the only time this has been a thing
we need 24,000 retweet by June 1st
this is posted just a few weeks before
we need 24,000 retweet by June 4 no
accounting final help us why why just
take the test like everyone else why did
the teacher agree to this yeah you know
what that's a lot of retweet I suppose
there will be no final who cares what
you learn or not if you can get a lot of
retweets on the internet that is the
most that is the most valuable source of
all time anything else has no real
importance or value learning things is
not important as retweets how about that
lesson to you kids so a lot of people
started to try and recreate this if we
can get five thousand retweets my
accounting class has no final twitter do
your thing go Twitter down
[Music]
yay oh you got 248 that's too bad
attention Twitter misses Kiska calculus
teacher had offers to give us three
student in the picture a passing grade
if this gets 25 thousand retweets please
help us with this Oh No it only got 78
retweets oh they're great
my heart bleeds for these students
wearing wearing a vest and a tie
I can't even tell who is the student and
who's the teacher these people are
struggling in school I've got 10 days
left come on guys
oh he tweeted ninja ninja please I'm
gonna injure please I need your help man
ninja why did you not retweet these what
the Frick dude you could have used your
friend influence so selfish some people
oh man I would have easily retweeted
this because this is just for a good
cause okay everyone hate school hashtag
I hate school too leave a like on this
video guys can we hit 50,000 likes in
school will just disappear that's right
my principal agreed upon it and if we
get 1 million likes my teacher will
perform seppuku and the whole school
system and the universe will disappear
the earliest example I can find of this
was in in December last year they asked
for 75,000 retweets to not get their
final exam in international marketing at
least if the subject is marketing and
you managed to get 50,000 retweets I
said I can sort of understand that but
just skipping your accounting exam is
just like why 500,000 retweets and mr.
Joseph will exempt our AP chemistry
final we have until May 17 come on guys
we this is a common common thing they
use to get you into the retweets oh I
get to be part of this joke retweet so
funny can you at least clean up your
whiteboard every single time it's all
American students - is it that bad
in America are you ok America 1k
retweets for the best teacher of LG
to add us on snapchat what you couldn't
even hit it pathetic all right
a thousand retweets do you know what
that is to me nothing it means nothing
to me
I absolutely garbage this is despicable
this whole thing reminds me of that
Indian friendship meme how great you're
all congratulations guys my teacher said
if we had 20,000 retweets he will let go
of my hand can we please do it oh man
there's stuck at 2600 damn guys can we
please retweet this to stop this abuse
some say they are still holding hands to
this date it's actually a very nice
romantic story again I can't tell who's
the teacher and the student what is
wrong with your school at Geralt Butler
my teacher mrs. Lemke is a huge fan and
says that if we can get ten thousand
retweets and a lunch date with you we
will all get hundred of our English
three final please help now this is just
sad this is sad because I know she'll do
it it's like all those guilt guilt
tweets about going to the prom hey if
this gets 20 thousand retweets
this celebrity will have to take me to
prom how many retweets for you to take
my senior photos with me twenty five
thousand and I get to wear this school
sweatshirt and hold a trombone how mean
worthy and exciting yeah yeah if this
video gets five likes I am going to
release nude photos of my dog please can
we make it happen everybody at Joseph's
strolling how many retweets for you to
wear my Sukup yep merch please respond
come on Internet let's make this happen
together together we can do it yeah yeah
at dis besito how many retweets to
remake it in Swedish please guys if the
internet works together we can make this
happen if I get five hundred thousand
retweets this can happen to me you
didn't even get it that's $4.99 by the
way pathetic at least get the right
amount it's literally just to become
like a marketing tool now for companies
look how many retweets yeah yeah I hate
everything I cannot feel joy anymore
help me
can we get 50 likes to help restore any
form of happiness in my heart please
guys can we do it 500 retweets and I'll
wear the Crocs for graduation
just do it oh you did anyway even though
you didn't get 500 no one cares hundred
retweets and I wear these babies to
graduation no one cares
150 retweets and I'll just do it I don't
care the internet is not your like
machine
how many retweets will it take for you
to go to prom with me 10k you know she's
saying you're basically ugly right Hey
look at that I got an air kiss for ten
ten thousand retweets great hey David
how many retweets for me to go on a date
with your mom twenty-five thousand
should be enough yes I'll treat her nice
it will be a good time guys help me get
thousand retweets so I can can my
awesome teacher to prom how about a
thousand retweets to make you learn how
to spell can my awesome teacher well
done well done good job it even got a
thousand almost like Jesus Christ help
her get five thousand retweets through
her teacher wrong how does that prove
your teacher wrong if anything you can't
spell despite having a Word document
help you autocorrect Jesus Christ
retweet for bonus meme while Brad to sad
much my wife said if I get 1 million
like I can name our son Goku just do it
I don't care
my wife boyfriend say if this post can
get 500 retweets he'll buy me an intense
wit please guys if there's one thing if
we all work together get this man a
Nintendo from his wife's boyfriend it's
for a good cause
dropping my new song monday if this gets
a hundred thousand retweets thousand
retweets ah that's the thing everyone
deletes them when they don't hit the
goal I see you okay I know what you're
up to
we need to shame these people Rita Ora
shame on you
by the way make Twitter get hacked
somebody's threatening to release new
music I've worked really hard on that no
one wants to hear listen it was funny
once I get it the whole retweet to get
Carter his nuggets it was funny it was
me mobile it was weird
okay and the fact that this tweet has
more retweets than Barack Obama tweet
there's something beautiful about that
but these cringy has kids just do your
homework instead next time how about
that and stop wasting my time I don't
want to see this thing I don't want to
hear about it just to stop thank you for
watching this video if we hit 5,000
likes I will enter this closet and I
will never come back that's right I'll
be waiting just let me know when we hit
okay just probably so let me know so I
know when to come out remember to why